se entregó la cuñada de pedro castillo
jennifer paredes acudió al ministerio
público después de dos intentos de
detención este miércoles la policía de
perú había entrado en la casa de pedro
castillo en tacabamba el martes lo hizo
en el palacio presidencial donde la
justicia nunca había accedido para una
detención una crisis en la que el
abogado del presidente y la primera dama
línea paredes renunció debo reiterar los
abogados no podemos ser juzgados por
quienes defendemos sino como defendemos
actuado con probidad y diligencia con
pasión y vehemencia criada como una hija
para pedro castillo el martes la corte
superior de justicia emitió una orden de
detención contra jennifer paredes por
diez días y por supuestamente participar
en una red de corrupción y lavado de
activos
consideran que el presidente es el
cerebro el martes dos representantes de
una empresa licitada por el estado en
2021 fueron detenidos también un alcalde
de cajamarca la región del presidente
considera que hay una persecución ciega
a través de esa agenda mediática en ese
show mediático coludidos
con sectores que nunca han hecho nada
por el perú quieren doblegar nos se le
acumulan las crisis a pedro castillo la
fiscalía inició cinco investigaciones en
su contra cuatro de ellas están activas
superó dos mociones de censura en el
congreso y ha tenido decenas de
dimisiones de ministros su desaprobación
es del 67 por ciento marcada por
escándalos y por la ingobernabilidad con
una mayoría conservadora en el congreso
estos parlamentarios incluso están peor
vistos con un 85% de desaprobación y con
el 65% de la población pidiendo
elecciones anticipadas